فيلم واحد يكتسح الاوسكار بسبع جوائز
ويقسم الاراء بين محبين وناقضين بشده وصور
مستشفى للامراض النفسيه في العراق تشعل
غضبا وانتقادات ودعوه قضائيه ضد اول محامي
روبوت في العالم اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
فجر اليوم الاثنين اقيم حفل الاوسكار
بنسخته ال 95 الجوائز الاشهر في عالم
السينما حول العالم فيلم واحد اكتسح الحفل
وفاز بسبع جوائز من اصل 11 جائزه اترشح
لها بنتكلم عن فيلم
بجوائز افضل ممثله وافضل ممثل مساعد وافضل
ممثله مساعده وافضل مخرج وافضل سيناريو
اصلي ايضا وافضل مونتاج وختمها كمان بافضل
فيلم والفيلم بيحكي قصه مالكه مغسله انهكت
هالمشاكل الاداريه مع سلطات الضرائب
فبتغوص في مجموعه عوالم موازيه الفيلم
بيجمع بين الحركه والكوميديا والخيال
العلمي وفوزه فتح نقاش كبير على فكره تكون
اغلبيه طاقم العمل من اصول اسيويه وهذا
الموضوع له رمزيه كبيره في هوليود اللي من
سنين متهمه بنقص التنوع وبدات مؤخرا تحاول
تغير هذا الموضوع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اما افضل ممثل فكانت مثل ما جاءت معظم
التوقعات البراند فريجر عن دورو في فيلم
دويل واللي بيحكي قصه مدرس بديل بينعزل في
منزله بيعاني الحزن فريجر سجل في هذا
الفيلم عوده قويه بعد سنوات من الغياب
وفاز بمعظم الجوائز الكبرى السينمائيا في
العالم هذا السنه وعاده بيكون في كثير
لحظات مؤثره في حفل الاوسكار بس كانه
السنه كانت الجرعه اضافيه خلينا نتوقف مع
ابرزها خاصه طبعا للفائزين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في لقطه ثانيه على فكره مؤثره جدا استوقفت
كمان كثيرين فلحظه تلقي فيلم
للجائزه الصعود الطاقم للمسرح كان النجم
حارس فورد هو اللي بيعلن الفائز وسلم
وبارك لطاقم الفيلم ومن ضمنهم الممثل
كيهوكوان اللي فاز عن الفيلم بجائزه افضل
ممثل مساعد ايضا ولحظه مطلع على المسرح
وسلم على حارسن فويد كثار من الناس تذكرت
فورا انه اول ظهور له كان في فيلم انديانا
جونز اندومي عام
1984 يعني من اربعين سنه وظهوره كان كطفل
وكان وقتها امام هاريسون وبما اننا بنتكلم
عن لقطات مميزه فخلينا كمان نحكي عن
لقطتين ثانيين لفته الانظار اولهم رده فعل
الممثله انجيلا كانت مرشحه لجائزه افضل
ممثله مساعده وخسرت الجائزه وخلينا نقول
انه رده فعلها ما كانت فيها روح رياضيه
ابدا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لقطه اخرى كانت لمقدمه الحفل جيمي واللي
من المتوقع ما قدر ما يجيب سيره اللقطه
الابرز في اوسكار العام الماضي صفات مثل
كريس
وهاب
اللي لافت كمان هذه المره كان تصريحات
سياسيه تبعت الحفل فافضل فيلم وثائقي كان
من نصيب اللي بيتناول قصه المعارض الروسي
اللي تسمم بغاز اعصاب في سيبيريا في 2020
وتعالج في المانيا المتحدث باسم الكرملين
صرح وقال ما راح اتكلم عن جوانب فنيه لاني
ما شفت الفيلم بس الاكيد انه في تسييس في
الموضوع بيقصد طبعا انه يعني امريكا فوزت
الفيلم لانه بيحكي عن معارض روسي
صغيره
ومديره قسم الافلام بجامعه اس اي اي دبي
اهلا فيك معانا يا رزان اول شيء انا عارفه
انك انت من المؤيدين للفيلم اللي اكتسح كل
شيء
وبيقولوا انه كانوا بيخرجوا من السينمات
ما كانوا بيكملوه حتى
ايش تحسي
اولا كل اوسكار وانتم بخير وانت بخير يا
رب ان شاء الله
الفيلم هذا طبعا فيلم خيال علمي فيلم
فانتازيا وطبعا يعني سمعنا حتى انه افلام
الجونرا اللي طول عمرها بتشتغل فيها افلام
الرعب هاي الافلام اللي هي مش دراما مش
افلام واقعيه افلام فيها خيال عالي وبمرات
بتكون صدمه للمشاهد الطبيعي لانه بحس احنا
متعودين على الشيء اللي متعودين عليه اللي
بنعرفه ايش يعني المشاهد الطبيعي يا رزان
يعني المشاهد اللي متعود يعني مش مثلا مش
المحبين افلام الجاره او متابعين الخيال
العلمي
مثلا اللي بيحضروا افلامهم يكونوا انهم
دخل في صناعه الافلام لانه تفهم يعني
مختلف او منظور مختلف للافلام اللي معموله
بالجاره معين كل الافلام الواقعيه اللي
قريبه من عالمنا احنا طيب بس الان يعني
الاختلاف في الموضوع على الفيلم هذا الناس
جالسه بتقول انه يعني صراحه انه الفيلم تم
تفويزه بكثير من الجوائز لانه معظم طاقم
العمل من اصول اسيويه وانه هذا الشيء اللي
بتحاول الاسكر وهليود تثبت انه ما في
عنصريه وفي يعني خلينا نقول تشمل الكل
يعني
هذا الكلام ما بينطبق اذا بنعرف وبنفهم
كيف المصوتين تبعون الاوسكارز اصلا بصوته
والجوائز هاي بتيجي من وين ممكن نحكي هذا
الكلام للترشيحات لانه الترشيحات تيجي من
الاكاديمي نفسها انه هم برشحوا بحاولوا
يعملوا بحاولوا يخلوا في ناس من طبقات او
من جهات ما كانش الها مكان زمان وما كانت
تترشح كفايه ولكن لما يجي للفوز في كتير
امور وعوامل الها خاص بالنقبات تبعت
الفنانين يعني جوائز الاخراج جوائز
الانتاج جوائز التصوير اللي بصوت عليها هم
ناس اللي في النقابه المخرجين والنقابه
المنتجين فيعني الموضوع بيجي له دخل
بالتكنيه والتكنيك تبع الاخراج او التصوير
او الانتاج اكثر من ما هو جهات سياسيه او
جهات مسؤوله الناس اللي بتصوت هي الناس
بتشتغل في صناعه الافلام بيكون الها علاقه
بالتكنيكل يعني قديش هذا الشيء
بنحس كمان يعني حرجعلك على نقطه الموضوع
السياسي لانه برضه حابب اتكلم معاكي عليها
او تسييس الامور لكن الناس بتحس انه يعني
احيانا كثيره اذا الفيلم منفهم انه هذا حق
الاوسكار هذا حق مهرجانات يعني كانه صايره
الافلام اللي تنفهم سبه يعني او انه
للطبقه العاديه يعني مو المثقفه
بالعكس فيلم زي هذا مش لا يعتبر انه لا
طبقه مثقفه او لا بالعكس هو من نوع
الافلام اللي عاده تتهمش افلام هذا اول
فيلم خيال علمي بياخد احسن جائزه اوسكار
اخر فيلم يعني يعتبر مش واقعي اخذ جائزه
احسن اوسكار
كانز يعني لو كان فانتازيا فهذه الافلام
عاده بالعكس ما بتحسي انه الجهات المثقفه
بتنظر لها انها للترفيه ولكن لما الخيال
العلمي او الفانتازي يتخذ بطريقه وينعمل
له يعني ابعاد اكثر من فقط الترفيه ممكن
يضرب على عصب الرسائل اللي فيها بطريقه
كتير حلوه وجميله وهذا الفيلم انجز هذا
الشيء بطريقه رهيبه انه قدر يكون فني وقدر
يكون تقني بطريقه جميله وبنفس الوقت يكون
مسكن ومضحك يعني هو كوميدي حتى يعني عاده
ما بياخذ جوائز مهرجانات ولا بالاسكر طيب
نحن كمان شفنا انه دخول يعني الكرملين على
الخط وبيقولوا انه في تسييس لانكم اخترتوا
الفيلم اللي عن المعارض الروسي قديش فعلا
يعني اصلا دائما يعني في اتهامات والاوسكر
بالتسيس يعني لانه حتى الفنانين لما
بيطلعوا احيانا كثير بيقولوا خطابات مسيسه
شوفي هلا بالنسبه للجوائز زي مثلا جوائز
الافلام الوثائقيه الفن يقلد الحياه
والحياه تقلد الفن يعني لما تعملي فيلم
وثائقي راح تطرحي مواضيع حاليا هي الها
دخل بالسياسه والها دخل بالحوار الاجتماعي
اللي عم بيصير بهديك اللحظه فاي شيء طبيعي
انه هاي الافلام يكون الها تعليق معين على
وضع سياسي او على دول او على اشياء احنا
بنعيش عمالنا في الايام اليوميه وبنشوفها
بالاخبار لانه فيلم وثائقي في هذا الشيء
بيجي يعني طبيعي ناتشر المعنى فلا ما بحس
انه هي فازت بهذا السبب بس انت لما تعطي
جوائز لافلام وثائقيه عدد الافلام وثائقيه
راح تتطرق لهذه المواضيع بطريقه طبيعيه
نقول هذا السنه كانت سنه مش طبيعي ما شاء
الله
بالتسعينات كنا نحضر له
يعني وهو كمان انسان يتهمش له قصه حزينه
يعني كيف تتهمش في عالم السينما وفي عالم
هوليود والبزنس بطريقه كتير
فالعوده تاعته هاي ورجعته اشي كتير جميل
للناس اللي بعمري اللي كانوا يحبوه لو
اختفى فجاه وهلا لقينار رجع وهي يعني قويه
والفيلم حلو كثير وتمثيله بالفيلم اصلا هو
اقوى شيء بفيلم دوالي يعني طبعا هم اخراج
بس مش من اقوى افلام
لمرحله كثير عاليه باداء رهيب والحقيقه كل
احد بيتكلم عن اداءه يعني وحصد كثير من
الجوائز احنا بنشكرك على هذه النظره
السريعه كانت معنا رزان طاش مراجعه
تلفزيونيه وسينمائيه ومديره قسم الافلام
بجامعه دبي شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
والى جانب الامور الفنيه ومناقشه الافلام
والجوائز الاوسكار هو محفل سنوي كمان
للفساتين واللبس ومثل العاده مختصين
الازياء هبوا فورا للتعليق فخلينا نستعرض
سريعا ابرز الاطلالات اللي حازت على
الافضل في حفل الا
حقيقه اختيار يعني ملالك رائع جدا لانه
كثير عجبنا كيف لبست اللي هو شيء مناسب
للحدث لكن طبعا في نفس الوقت بيمثل هويتها
وطبعا يعني اصلا دعوتها اللي حدث مثل هذا
يعني برضو شيء جميل يعني كمان لكن على
الجانب الاخر في نجمات ثانيات ما كانوا
موفقين خلينا نقول بحسب الخبراء وسميت
اطلالاتهم بالاسوا خلينا نشوف
اهلا من جديد مستشفى الرشاد التدريبي
للامراض النفسيه والعقليه في الرصافه في
بغداد حديث العراقيين على المنصات والسبب
صور انتشرت للمستشفى عملت حاله من الغضب
الواسع
الصور اللي شفناها مع بعض قيل انها
لمستشفى الرشاد التدريبي للامراض النفسيه
والعقليه في بغداد اللي تاسس عام 1950
وحقيقه واضح انه من وقتها من عمل لتجديد
او تحسين لمرافقه فاللي بيشوف الصور
مستحيل يتخيل انه ممكن يكون هذا المكان
للرعايه الصحيه والنفسيه لانه بيفتقد
لابسط
مستلزمات الرعايه والناس صارت تقول المريض
النفسي اللي تعبان وجاي علشان يتعالج
ويتاهل نفسيا راح تسوق حالته اصلا يعني لا
نظافه ولا مرافق ولا شيء ومن سنوات
العراقيين بيتكلموا عن معاناه المستشفى من
قله الكوادر الطبيه والخدمات والعلاجات
والمستلزمات المطلوبه للحالات اللي
بيستقبلها وكان عضو مجلس النواب السابق
رعد الماس كمان وصف المستشفى انه مقبره
للاحياء بس يبدو انه على الرغم من انه مرت
سنوات على هذا الكلام بس وضع المستشفى لسه
مثل ما هو ويمكن صار اسوا والعراقيين
نزلوا على المنصات تعبير عن استياء وغضب
من اللي شافوه
الفكره المستشفى هذه كان زارا من عشره
ايام بالتحديد مدير صحه الرصافه ورافقوا
كمان مستشار الصحه النفسيه في وزاره الصحه
وعملوا جوله في المستشفى وتفقدوا الخدمات
المقدمه واثنوا على جهود المدير العام
للمستشفى كمان والعاملين فيها
في بدايه السنه كنا تناولنا خبر انه شركه
دوناتي بتخطط على شان انها تستخدم رابط
محامي داخل قاعه المحكمه لاول مره هذا
الروبوت بقدم منشوره قانونيه للمدعي عليه
وبيساعده طيب قامت الدنيا وما قعدت عن
الموضوع لدرجه ان المدير الشركه تعرض
لتهديدات من نقابه المحاميين والعقوبه
السجن وقال انه اجلت الموضوع طيب المفاجاه
اليوم ان الروبوت المحامي هذا اللي بيتكلم
عنه بيواجه هو نفسه دعوه قضائيه رفعها
عليه احد العملاء اللي استعانوا فيه فاللي
صار انه الرجل استعان بخدمات شركه دونات
باي لكتابه وثائق قانونيه مختلفه لكن
الوثائق ما عجبته وكانت دون المستوى
المطلوب ووقت تعرف انه اللي كتب المستندات
هو المحامي الروبوت
راح لجا لمكتب محاماه ورفع دعوه ضد الشركه
صاحبه المحامي الروبوتو فحوى الدعوه انه
هذا الروبوت المحامي بيمارس مهنه المحاماه
من دون ترخيص
مدير الشركه تبع مسكت انه راح يدافعوا عن
نفسهم وكنوع من التحدي كمان كتب في تغريده
انه احتمال يستخدم الروبه المحامي نفسه في
هذه القضيه
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم انا
عود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم دائما تابعوا مقاطعنا
على حساباتنا على مواقع التواصل وطبعا على
يوتيوب وممكن تشوفونه كمان على شاهد
الحلقات كامله حلقات رائعه على ضمانتي في
امان الله
[موسيقى]